head head head we got coca man you gotta
cut them in half that's that's the
classic way okay we're not we're not
we're not
Criss Angel or anything we don't cut our
heads off and pull them back together we
cut the torsos off can you do pourcel I
mean that's show them the head trick
[Music]
hello again welcome back to potato mode
the show where we take the most
beautiful games we know turn them into
mush right here alongside me is Rob
handler me once again hey thanks for
having me back and today magic is in the
air because we are playing fallout 4
right here probably one of my favorite
things about the game is that you can
give your own story to whoever you want
whatever character you make role-playing
and so today because I love magic so
much I used to love it a whole lot as a
kid used to watch it all the time
here we have the greatest 90's stage
magician of all time yes and that's
Lance Burton
[Music]
he has been living in the waistline for
a good couple decades you know traveling
in and out between Vegas and whatnot but
now that everything is destroyed he is
feeling down he wants to get back on his
feet and we need to help so we have to
help him be on the show
mhm storm 2 is a former self and maybe
bring a little bit of joy to this
forsaken place Oh Strong's back though I
killed him
ok so what's first I think you gotta go
you gotta looked apart right
we need this tuxedo sir I was a little
close
well let's admire this for a second look
at the boot you got the paint stains got
a little boat on yeah I like the red and
white though I love it
alright we are ready for a show of
course no magic show is complete without
an audience all right you're gonna need
an audience to have a magic show or else
you're a big dumb loser
all right we've transported ourselves
here how I'm never gonna reveal that but
we have ourselves at this stage a couple
of volunteers I'm sure we'll be glad to
help out tell me something that's guys
you ever feel like this whole world yep
shop thank you yeah so for my first
trick and we'll need a volunteer yeah he
opened up by killing a man you right
there this is the creep would you would
you like to help me no way that's super
me you right here sir can you please
stand right here and don't move I will
be removing all of your settings in just
a second tada
okay here's the game running at a good
it's below 720 all the settings are
turned off and you can see in the seams
of the the buildings and the corners of
everything they're starting to come
apart I don't know if we should show
this to show this dojo then Joey I don't
know if the audience is that impressed
they're more interested in the
smoldering tires that's okay because as
a magician you never just have one trick
you always have two sleeves alright so
for my second trick I will need another
volunteer you
in the Hat please stop running away from
me preston garvey
if you would please come with me no
please don't run away that's ok our
volunteer ran away but don't worry I'm
still gonna go on with the show
everyone right here is going to be the
volunteer so if you all will just close
your eyes and dream of something
something nice open your eyes ok
magicians never reveal their secrets
I'll show them for my final trick Oh
illusion whatever you want to call it
we're gonna be going to wherever you
want so just pick up just close your
eyes and think of any place what is a
place that makes you the happiest you
know I want to go Nuka world noise yeah
let's see all those rides Diamond City
it is alright we are in the most
beautiful place in the world this is
your dream spot right this is it this is
yep this is what I wanted how can we get
in here without permission sir way
you could fly oh yeah that's right we
can fly anywhere we want because we are
magic
this is not how I remember it
I'm pretty sure this was supposed to be
populated right not loading every time
you touch the ground you might have a
different position oh man I've never
I've never imagined flying like like
looking like this there's a weird game
it's magic for you okay sweet we made
our way in this is the vacation spot of
your dreams I know I like how the
mannequins look exactly like everyone
else
I'm sorry scuse me
yeah we thought you were real oh my god
this guy is bait
you said nuchal world right yeah that's
where you want to go fine
I love Nuka world this is just all part
of the the theme park atmosphere right
excuse me I know you guys love magic but
you're gonna have to appreciate the
magician space once in a while tell me
your secrets
head head we got you gotta cut them in
half that's that's the classic way okay
we're not we're not we're not Criss
Angel or anything we don't cut our heads
off and pull them back together we cut
the torsos off can you do torso I mean
that's show them the head trick that's a
good trick is there like a giant
circular saw that we can use about a
Chinese officer sword that works yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I can only go for
the head she loves magic magic
like instead of putting them in the box
of selling them have to just stay there
just hacks away for like 10 minutes at
their arms oh it's coming don't worry
just like start sweating getting all
like run oh we go see what'd I tell you
all right you can return to your seat
you've been a great help
thank you so much yeah who wants to
volunteer next me
they could speak they would definitely
be saying this thing has a rocket on it
[Laughter]
right now
stop it wait your turn alright everyone
thank you so much you've been a great
audience see you next time
all right so now that we put on the
greatest show on earth I feel like it's
time to just relax a little bit you know
I think Lance has earned his his right
to a vacation and the best way for a
magician taking vacations to just
teleport there right yep I would think
so
this person died watching other people
die how sad
this is the worst vacation spot you
could have ever picked about one more
Bunker Hill Bunker Hill poof yeah
perfect yep yep Wow sorry sorry nothing
it's it's just me it's me Lance Burton
the world's greatest stage magician okay
come on through and my sidekick strong
but beautiful my beautiful assistant all
right so why are we here again I don't
know we just need a nice comfy bed to
rest our rest our weary brain the
monument how you get up there beats me I
don't really remember you did flop I
knew I knew you're gonna do this this is
the ending that Lance Burton deserves
you really are a magician whether it was
the you know it's gonna change me nice
and sunny oh okay that's it this is
successful we'll end on here if you guys
have a suggestion for a game that you'd
like to see you know potato fight just
leave in the comments below you can
tweet at me tweet at Rob even if he
allows it sure that's fine and we will
see you guys next Friday every Friday
for the rest of our lives
whoa maybe not that long but I'll see
you guys definitely next Friday for
another potato mode game I haven't quite
decided yet but we'll see I feel really
happy man I'm glad I was able to help
out Lance in his journey for redemption
as you would say yeah it's magic has
been restored to the Commonwealth is
Magic in the air or that just radiation
oh my god what is going on it's the
worst plastic surgery operation I've
ever had in my life how did you get here
oh I don't know but we're here we did it
all right everyone thank you so much for
watching and we will see you guys next
time
[Music]
oh wait this whole life I'm taking it
back oh yeah